et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec michèle leflon présidente de la
coordination nationale des comités de
défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité
bonjour mais c'est le fort merci d'être
avec nous avant de rentrer dans le
détail des mesures
globalement est ce que vous êtes plutôt
satisfaite de ces annonces d'olivier
verrons aujourd'hui mais je pense que
heureusement qu'il ya des luttes parce
qu'on l'a bien vu avec les salaires les
revalorisations de salaires ont augmenté
au fur et à mesure que de nouvelles
journées d'action se passer donc c'est
pour la même chose ya effectivement un
certain nombre d'acquis mais c'est quand
même très minimaliste très très
minimaliste parce que quand on sait que
dans le beaucoup de services d'urgence
les patients restent sur des brancards
faute de lits 4010 saisonniers
d'arcachon pour reprendre l'expression
d'olivier dahan
c'est quand même extrêmement minimaliste
quand on sait y compris pour continuer
sur arcachon casse à la réole dans le
même département lice le service de
soins non programmés et fermée pendant
l'été pour peut-être qu'on ouvre des
lits d'arcachon mais c'est quand même il
n'y a pas de véritable réponse au
problème sur lequel de bâton la
proximité pour l'ensemble de la
population ou qu'elle habite et on sait
qu'actuellement quand j'ai parlé des
urgences surchargées
c'est beaucoup paris mais c'est aussi
ces et les difficultés d'accès aux soins
c'est c'est la réole cd maternité qu'on
envisage de fermer on ne fait aucun
effort pour quoi recruter des
gynécologues
c'est hier soir il y avait une réunion
publique à dinan en bretagne c'est digne
les bains où la pop et la population des
soignants de se mobiliser pour qu'on
recrute qu'on cherche des médecins parce
que la direction était parti du principe
que c'était pas la peine d'en chercher
comme ça c'est plus simple de fermer
alors olivier veyron c'est quand même a
tardé
sur ce mot qui est devenu j'allais dire
à la mode ironiquement enfin les
territoires la décentralisation est ce
que vous pensez quand même même si tout
se fait pas d'un coup que cela va dans
le bon sens qui a une prise de
conscience qu'il faut décentraliser
aller vers plus d'autonomie dans les
territoires et que c'est comme cela on
va arriver à un bon résultat que vous
souhaitez et il y as besoin d'autonomie
dans les territoires mais de quelle
autonomie par le taux j'ai aussi entendu
ce matin rollier gérant la ministre à la
cohésion des territoires dire que les
collectivités pour avoir plus de rôle si
c'est effectivement pour discuter des me
des mesures décidées proposée par l'état
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'il faut
les adapter aux territoires
si c'est pour qu'on le demande aux
collectivités qui sont déjà exsangues
financièrement de financer des
investissements pour la santé c'est une
catastrophe
clairement pour vous madame aujourd'hui
quelle est la priorité absolue c'est
injecter de l'argent il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui a été injecté quand même
dans les hôpitaux une enveloppe encore
de 50 millions d'euros 1 permettant de
créer ces 4000 lits dont vous parliez
qu'est ce qui est plus important cet
argent là où justement des mesures
présentées comme ils le disent
restructurant sur l'organisation et la
gouvernance du système est ce que ce
n'est pas justement une refonte totale
du système qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour peut-être dépenser
moins d'argent et faire mieux
il y a besoin d'argent
il y as besoin d'avoir un hôpital qui
fonctionne bien pour avoir un service de
soins de proximité qui fonctionne bien
les deux doivent être forts et c'est pas
l'un contre l'autre et nous nous pensons
au niveau de la coordination qui compris
c'est au tour de services publics locaux
y compris autour d'un service de soins
de premier recours dans les territoires
autour des centres de santé d'un service
public que il vous faut organiser
organiser les choses mais bien
évidemment il faut aussi une gouvernance
adaptée
et en termes de démocratie y compris on
peut se poser la question comment va
être utilisé cet argent alors le corbeau
est supprimée il va être remplacé par
une autre instance pour l'instant très
clairement quand des représentants de la
coordination nationale des comités de
défense posent leur candidature
un conseil de surveillance si l'on
malheur de déplaire aux représentants de
la rs dans leur département eh ben ils
sont pas retenus y compris donc c'est
comment on assure une véritable
démocratie nous nous pensons aussi qu'il
faut revenir à des élections des
administrateurs de la sécurité sociale
pour avoir une démocratie dont
l'utilisation de cet argent collectif
qui est celui de sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui à la lumière de ce que vous
avez entendu lors de ce ces cures de la
santé est ce que vous avez clairement un
espoir raisonnable que certaines
maternités par exemple puisque vous vous
occupez de cela aussi rouvre des
maternitantes vous mettre un était
ferrée était fermée dans des endroits
voilà peut-être plus isolé après
d'autres j'ai écouté l'ensemble de la
conférence de presse je n'ai pas entendu
olivier vers l'avenir et ce qu'on voit
sur le terrain
c'est bien le contraire de ça et c'est
pour ça que je vous ai cité un certain
nombre d'exemples donc pour nous bien
évidemment les milliards versés à
l'hôpital on prend on est d'accord à
condition qu'ils soient utilisés
correctement et pas pour compliquer pour
compliquer l'accès aux soins de toutes
et tous parce que y compris si on fait
plus de chambres eux seuls et qu'on
demande aux gens de payer le forfait
chambres individuelles en les obligeant
à le payer par des mesures et on en a
plein d'exemples sur comment on force
les gens à prendre le forfait chambres
individuelles
il faut pas que l'argent dépensé se
retourne contre l'accès aux soins et de
ce point de vue nous avons besoin aussi
d'une véritable démocratie en santé
merci beaucoup me faire le flon
présidente de la coordination nationale
des comités de défense des hôpitaux et
maternités
proximité merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france